all right we're getting closer to the bb
can 10 premiere and to get you even more
pumped for the new season let's check
back in with erisa cox to get the scoop
hey erisa sangeeta season 10 can you
believe this yes congrats on 10 seasons
this is a huge milestone could you have
imagined getting to this point blazing
into season 10. i am so grateful i am so
humbled that this thing that we love
that we make
has been so embraced by the country and
that we're still here i know this game
inside out so how will you be
celebrating the 10th season on the show
we want to keep blazing into the future
we are always leaders in this genre so
we were like no let's make it shiny and
new and fresh but let's fill it with
easter eggs that call back to different
seasons and different twists and
different houseguests i think i have a
pretty sweet party trick
[Music]
now this show is seen as one of the best
versions of big brother in the world how
does bb can 10 raise that bar
well one thing you know about this show
is that we are
the most extra show on canadian
television we are
if you can if you can take it to a
hundred we'll take it to 150 that's
always what we've done this is
wild this is a season that is really
shouting out the the true heart of big
brother
in that it is the greatest game on earth
what excites you the most about the new
cast i really think we have so many
things that we have to get right we have
to try to represent so many different
kinds of people and regions and
ethnicities and backgrounds and
knowledge of the game all of those
things shape the cast that we have now
if you could give the house guest one
piece of advice before entering the
house what would it be well you know
we'd like to keep the house guests on
their toes that's one thing you'll find
that the people who succeed in big
brother canada are the ones that are
able to adapt to whatever we are
throwing at these guys and it is a lot
they can't be as good at this game as i
am
arisa big brother canada is known for
crazy comps and epic twists sometimes on
the first night what can fans expect are
there surprises
always i mean first of all we're
surrounded by doors
so many mystery doors and so many
different things are going to be behind
these doors
i don't want to give too much away
because i do want you to watch because
it is going to be such a killer premiere
we are so
excited all right we're just minutes
away from the season 10 premiere of big
brother canada but first more with the
new house guests when we return
[Music]